[Musique]
m
charles et diana salut les terriens je
suis très heureux de me retrouver notre
invité principal ce soir c'est une
émouvante
les beaux arts bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
ici ce soir pour répondre à la question
que tout le monde se pose depuis des
années comment se fait-il que chaque
fois qu'on monte dans un taxi en entende
les grosses têtes parce qu'il ya de la
bonne humeur parce que de temps en temps
on apprend quelque chose et parce que
finalement à la radio beaucoup plus que
à la télé on parle dans l'oreille des
gens
[Musique]
est ce que vous auriez un mot pour
remercier vos amis chauffeur de taxi
philippe oui je leur dirais que ce sont
deux délicieux compteur
[Musique]
oui
finalement je l'étais plus fidèles à rtl
qu à votre femme non oui beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus mais il ya du passage dans
une station radio
alors philippe en p1 nous serons tous
les deux nous parlerons de vous de vos
origines de votre enfance de votre
succès de votre longévité de votre mort
bref tout ce que vous racontez dans le
livre que vous publié chez flammarion ma
vie d'avant ma vie d'après voilà qu'elle
vit j'ai bien conservés en plus vous
faites pas du tout vos 80 non oui je
fais un peu plus n'ont fait 80 au
maximum
alors on paie 2 nous accueillerons de
nouveau invité pour discuter avec nous
de ceux qui ont fait l'actualité de la
semaine
christiane taubira députée de guyane
christiane
taubira la guyanaise la plus célèbre
après rien 4 évidemment toujours en p2
nous accueillerons bruno gaccio pour son
livre la révolution
on se rappelle chez descartes et
compagnie bruno gaccio découvrir par
vous philippe bouvard qui nous dira s'il
fait partie de ceux qui vous sont
reconnaissants de les avoir lancés ou de
ceux qui vous en valent 2 avoir payé
comme des roumains
en p3 après les zappings et guillon nous
accueillerons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir lorenzo fumagalli
assistants sexuels c'est marrant que ça
choque les gens comme ça les assistants
sexuels vous avez eu beaucoup philippe
des assistantes sexuelles oui c'est un
truc qu'on peut pas faire tout seul pour
faire quand on a dépassé un certain
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens le groupe
non
puis pour un rebond soir alors on se
souviendra peut-être de vous comme le
petit bonhomme rigolo qui sautait sur
son siège quand jacques martin ou carlos
faisait une blague mais ce sera pas
faute d'avoir écrit des livres vous avez
écrit 54 ans le dernier s'appelle ma vie
d'avant ma vie d'après c'est publié chez
flammarion alors dans le précédent en
2009 je suis mort et alors vous
racontiez votre trépas et avec le
nouveau là vous livrer vos mémoires
d'outre-tombe voyez c'est à dire qu'il
s'est écoulé dix ans depuis mon île
humain sur sa passe très vite d'ailleurs
c'est bien qu'on ait pas grand chose à
faire alors pour nous livrer vos
réflexions sur la vie sur la mort à
coups de bons mots et d'aphorismes c'est
aussi très intime un oui oui très à vous
a choqué parce que je connais votre
pudeur oui
non par exemple c'est la première fois
que vous évoquez dans un livre aux
origines juives
vous dites mon père avait hérité de ses
parents morts en déportation
une minuscule résidence secondaire à
montmorency donc on entend déportation
on se dit voilà et puis à un moment vous
rencontrez un rabbin qui vous demande
son chemin à cannes et puis il me
regarde un peu plus ils disent ne seriez
vous pas monsieur moubarak dit oui eh
bien vous savez votre notre communauté
vous apprécie beaucoup je lui dis ben
sans doute connaît-elle nos attaches
mais je vous préviens monsieur le rabbin
je ne crois pas en dieu et là il me dit
c'est quand même dieu qui a permis par
le plus grand des hasards qu'un juif de
bande son chemin un autre chemin vous
êtes juif salomon alors
[Musique]
vous êtes né le 6 décembre 1929 à
coulommiers donc votre père biologique
en fait est catholique
votre mère est juive d'origine
alsacienne s'appelle gintzburger et
votre père adoptif et juifs on vous dit
je ne suis pas en train d'être juif mais
je vois pas de raison de clamer non plus
mon nom mais ça explique si vous voulez
que j'ai eu pendant quatre années
crucial du rhin dans une adolescence des
moments difficiles ouais vous étiez en
fuite en fait vous n'arrêtez pas de
déménager et aujourd'hui encore vous
craignez finalement oui la nuit quand il
a commis la nuit quand on sonne trop tôt
le matin chez vous ça vous plaît pas
quoi non pas du tout pas d'un pouce ça
me rappelle des mauvais souvenirs de la
même façon c'est complètement ridicule
que quand il y avait des bruits de
guerre insistant je faisais acheter des
conserves pour remplir les placards et
préférant alors votre note et opticienne
et votre père tailleurs pour homme vos
parents s'adoraient mais se disputer
sans arrêt ça allait jusqu'aux menace de
divorce oui et il ya quelque chose de
très touchant que j'avais dit c'est que
tous les soirs vous montiez vous couchez
avec les yeux pleins de larmes oui c'est
pour ça que j'étais un petit garçon
malheureux parce que je ne savais pas
que c'était un jeu de rôle mais qu' il
s' adorait en réalité et puis je les
laissais vers minuit en train de se
menacer l'un de divorce l'hôte de police
secours est naturellement j'étais pas au
courant de la réconciliation qui suivait
alors il n'y avait pas d'argent chez
vous on vous dit quand on parlait
d'argent la maison c'était pour parler
des femmes moins angoissante ou
s'extasier sur la richesse des nantis y
avait pas de jalousie semara du nepad
envie non enfin si une certaine envie de
delon ressemblait plus tard oui alors
pour votre huitième anniversaire vos
parents vous amène à cannes voilà vous
prenez le train de nuit et vous vous
retrouvez sur la sur la croisette ah oui
ça c'est mon grand souvenir je découvre
à la fois la mère que je n'ai jamais vu
je découvre ses très beaux hôtels sur la
croisette et puis il ya une vieille
voiture qui s'arrête devant nous et il
descend de cette voiture un monsieur
avec le visage émacié une belle couronne
de cheveux argentés et ma mère dit c'est
jean cocteau et
mon père ajoute le poète est alors
pendant des années je me suis imaginé
que les poètes étaient des gens très
riches qui avaient tous un chauffeur en
voyant cannes vous vous jurer d'habiter
là un jour c'est ce qui est le cas
d'ailleurs visibilité plus de la moitié
de la semaine aujourd'hui et j'imagine
qu'en voyant la voiture qui était celle
de francine weisweiller qui était une
map ford oui vous vous dites un jour
j'aurai une once quoi aujourd'hui j'ai
pas énormément de fierté mais quelques
satisfaction celle d'avoir réalisé trois
rêves d'enfants je voulais des grosses
voitures ils fassent oublier que j'étais
tout petit je voulais occupé quand je
suis devenu journaliste le fauteuil de
pierre lazareff point qui était mon
idole professionnels et puis je voulais
avoir une bibliothèque avec beaucoup de
livres et naturellement avec une échelle
pour y parvenir et ben voila je suis une
dans livre raconte également les
ecclésiastiques tripoteur les tripotages
avec les copains et puis les filles en
fait vous avez été déniaisé par votre
bonne oui comme ça se passait sous la
table de la salle à manger et qu'il y
avait un très grand tapis ça a été mon
initiation au camping
personne n'a été au courant longtemps
est ce qui fait que la bonne me
conduisait au lycée ce qui faisait
rigoler tous les copains mais moi je
rigolais à l'intérieur parce que je
savais que je couchais avec les voilà
d'où le nom de vol à tout faire
c'est lui le certificat d'études mais
jamais le bac non jamais c'était pas
grave à l'époque parce que les
autodidactes avait encore une petite
place dans la société si vous allez au
centre de formation des journalistes
en fait je dirais oui précédemment j'ai
fait douze lycées trois cours privés et
là bas au bout de trois mois on me met à
la porte mais on met à la porte parce
que j'ai révélé un certain talent de
plume vous faisiez commerce de devoir je
les vendais
wii qui avait moins de plumes mais
davantage d'argent et mais alors après
il y en a eu quatre cinq six jamais plus
le temps de différencier alors qu'on la
mèche a été éventée ce jour là j'ai dû
prendre la porte avec d'ailleurs à un
petit papier qui trône à la place
d'honneur dans mon bureau le directeur
avait écrit à ma mère il n'est pas doué
pour le journalisme mais il réussira
dans les carrières commerciales abadie
dans
[Musique]
alors ensuite fait plein de petits
boulots vendeurs d'encyclopédie lancé la
honte de ma vie ah oui je vendais des
encyclopédies en anglais à des français
analphabètes ah oui et payable en 18
mois avec elle dans son horreur
l'horreur et puis j'ai vendu des
lunettes de soleil mais c'était un été
pluvieux le grand chose et puis j'ai
donné des des leçons jacques rené à lire
à des enfants retardé parmi tous ces
petits boulots vous en faites un qui
vous amènera au sommet vous rentrez
comme garçon de course au service photo
du figaro et un jour vous êtes nommé
sous chef du service photo quand il ya
un incendie à marseille 45 morts et là
vous faites venir la photo par bellino
grave c'est une sorte de saxe de photos
voilà j'ai un sac de couchage et toutes
les nuits je suis au journal en
attendant la chance et un jour ben elle
se produit dramatiquement avec
l'événement vous évoquez puis le
lendemain le figaro est le seul
quotidien national à voir voilà cette
photo à la une alors le grand patron
demande comment ça s'est passé on lui
parle de moi ont présenté et puis
quelques jours plus tard j'ai de
l'avancement et je deviens enfin
vraiment journaliste voilà
[Applaudissements]
en carrière
il ya un autre truc aussi qui vous a
permis de devenir journaliste c'est que
vous aviez pour habitude d'aller aux
toilettes en même temps que le patron
brice ans j'avais remarqué que comme
c'était un homme d'habitude ils allaient
satisfaire un besoin naturel
tous les soirs à la même alors je
mettais à côté de la vasque qui lui
était réservé et puis j'attendais et
puis l'arrivée et puis bah au bout de
trois semaines de ce petit manège jusque
là il m'avait rien dit il m'adresser la
parole parce qu'il ya une espèce de
fraternité entre des gens qui sont en
train de l'avant-port même temps et et
me dit
un peu inattendu il me dit est ce que
vous travaillez ici
ça ne vient pas que pour pisser
et puis
il me dit vous êtes heureux bas ce
serait encore plus si je pouvais
vraiment faire du reportage et et/ou
d'un moment il m'a dit ben venez on va
en parler dans le bureau et je suis
devenu un de ses poulains que j'ai
obtenu tous les postes jusqu'à quitter
le figaro 22 ans plus tard avec le titre
de directeur
alors ça c'est la presse
ça c'est la presse et la télé bon samedi
soir où vous m'avez tous montrés
philippe c'est parce que je vous ai vu
que je suis comme ça sinon suis gentil
donc il ya eu samedi soir il ya eu le
petit théâtre de bouvard évidemment et
puis à la radio les grosses têtes qui a
commencé en 1977 alors au départ c'est
un concept d'avant-guerre les
incollables les incollables et jean
pharand le patron de rtl dit écoutez
philippe on commence un 1er avril comme
ça si ça vous plait pas si ça marche pas
le 2 avril on dira que c'était une
blague ce formidable c'était ya près de
35 ans voilà j'ai pas une petite crise
de la 82ème non non j'ai eu
la crise de la cinquantaine
grosse tête et puis
à 70 ans alors la panique totale un
arrêt total je dis non seulement bon je
suis un vieux mais on va plus vouloir de
moi nulle part comme je ne sais que
travailler je sais pas ce que je vais
devenir à quoi je vais occuper mes
journées et je m'attendais vraiment à
être lâché de tous les côtés par tout le
monde et puis bon ben j'ai attendu trois
mois six mois rien et puis bon bain et
salle et ont passé et je suis toujours
là mais pas un peu trop jeune pour votre
âge non
mais bruno gaccio ont discuté avec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les carrières rebond sur le
cayenne nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de philippe bouvard
ayant chritiane taubira bonsoir
et bruno gaccio
qui servira bonsoir je voudrais tout
d'abord vous féliciter pour votre
courage parce que vous êtes la seule
femme au monde à avoir accepté de se
retrouver entre philippe bouvard bruno
gaccio et thierry ardisson
cela me change de l'assemblée c'est à
ces kamikazes là ce soir alors vous êtes
député radical de gauche de guyane
depuis 1993 vous resterez dans
l'histoire de république pour avoir fait
reconnaître la traite et l'esclavagé
comme crime contre l'humanité c'est la
fameuse loi taubira grâce à vous
aujourd'hui on dit plus j'ai un esclave
on dit j'ai un stagiaire
alors moins réussi l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 pour le parti
radical de gauche
résultat 2,32 % des voix on vous a
accusé à l'époque d'avoir disperser les
voix de gauche et empêché lionel jospin
d'être au deuxième tour oui vous avez
noté que c'est surtout moi qu'on a plus
de cela alors que nous étions plusieurs
candidats de gauche j'étais certainement
la plus loyale parce que j'étais la
seule à ne pas taper sur monsieur jospin
je crois que les français ne s'y sont
pas trompés lorsqu'on n'est pas capable
d'assumer ses responsabilités de prendre
sur soi ses erreurs et ses défaites je
pense qu'on ne mérite pas forcément
d'accéder aux plus hautes
responsabilités dans ce pays et
notamment à la magistrature suprême
mais
est-ce que nous imaginer qu'une femme
noire aurait pu être président de la
république alors que vous n'aimez pas de
rentrer dans les boîtes de nuit ici
en tout cas pour les personnes que j'ai
rencontrées au moins pour les sept cent
mille personnes qui ont voté pour moi
oui c'était tout à fait concevable ça
n'était pas une extravagance alors en
2007 vous n'étiez pas candidate et
pourtant le parti socialiste a perdu
quand même voilà cqfd et après sarkozy
vous a proposé d'entrer au gouvernement
est ce que vous pensez que vous auriez
fine une rama yade acceptable non de
toute façon j'ai refusé parce que je
n'aurais pas été capable d'appliquer le
programme d'un candidat que j'ai
critiqué pendant toute la campagne
pourquoi il vous a proposé alors à parce
que je pense qu'il se prend pour un
chasseur
alors pour la prochaine présidentielle
vous avez décidé de soutenir arnaud
montebourg alors audrey pulvar
christiane taubira qu'est ce que vous
les trouvez tout un montebourg dans les
dom tom
voilà une chose qu'on devrait forcément
ouais
mais me chercher nous avons des
convergences politiques
c'est de me regarder comme ça d'abord il
est beau
garrett et toi
tu passes la vie à draguer les filles
donc là ce soir c'est une c'est une
députée en france je pense plus je suis
des jeunes vieille dame dans au nom
prédestiné autres ce genre de technique
des noms adresse toi regarde moi dans
les yeux
il est inférieur je vous disais que j'ai
de grandes convergences politiques avec
amour depuis plusieurs années contre les
paradis fiscaux contre les fonds
vautours montebourg je n'ai pas envie de
subir quelqu'un qui a des chances de
gagner plutôt non moi je ne dirais pas
aujourd'hui arnaud n'a aucune chance
mais en tout état de cause je ne fais
jamais de choix sur des bases ni
opportuniste ni carriériste ni parasite
ce que dit arnaud est très très en
tandem et bon voilà c'est sympa il sera
de plus en plus belles tenues
location soir alors comme smaïl les
inconnus chevallier laspalès mimie mathy
michèle bernier muriel robin vous devez
tout à philippe bouvard est-ce qu'il
doit encore quelque chose philippe se
prendront d un jour financé je pense
qu'on est à jour si nous a donné tous
les soirs entre 15 12 et 15 millions de
personnes pendant deux ans ouais parce
qu'à l'époque avait que trois chaînes on
a comme reiss était très loin mais bon
nous regarder où on allait se coucher
quoi d'autre choix mais quand vous avez
vu un journaliste qui roulait en ferrari
en roll ça vous a pas semblé un peu une
arme quand même non c'est pas ça qui
m'avait semblé une arnaque au départ
soit l ensemble de la carrière la rolls
était la conséquence de l'arnaqué maison
à cannes je me souviens nous avait dit
on sort discrètement de l'hôtel parce
qu'on allait faire un gala privé chez
paco on prenait de l'oseille comme ça en
douce on sort très discrètement donc il
nous fait dormir love vs d'hôtel énorme
et viennent nous chercher avec une rolls
décapotable
alors vous avez déclaré aujourd'hui chez
canal+ avec mon unité de fiction la
fabrique geci de faire ce qu'il faisait
oui en donnant leur chance à des jeunes
et je me suis aperçu que j'étais bouvard
dhien dans ma façon de trancher
ouais parce que philippe faisait une
chose on passait devant lui
il avait une préférence pour les
inconnus smaïn qui faisait débuter ici
passer les premiers ensuite il y avait
bernard campan il y avait moi 22 gens
qui passaient et ils disaient oui ou non
sans jamais donner une explication bien
se marrer ou pas a récemment three posé
la bombe oui oui on a enregistré non
d'ailleurs enfin c'était aussi rapide
mais plus courtois a fait en fait le
seul critère c'était est-ce que c'est
rigolo je pensais que si je riais les
téléspectateurs rire à 11 il suffit de
le faire marrer ça marche mais ce qui
veut dire que parfois on allait un peu
sous la ceinture passe plus de choses
sur la ceinture que tu eu
ces accès au dessus ça fonctionne pas en
dessous ça marche pas non plus
je pense que vous expliquer tout à
l'heure j'étais téméraires alors bruno
votre nouveau livre s'appelle la
révolution on se rappelle ses publié
chez descartes et compagnie art le pitch
est pourquoi les pauvres ne se révolte
pas ça commence avec un clochard donc
acquis vous refuser de donner un euro et
qui vous dit merci monsieur brune
journée je lui rentre dedans et j'ai été
choqué par la dignité de sa misère et je
lui ai dit mais vole mois sans un
couteau pic - prends moi l'argent sauf
moi dessus prends-moi les trucs et non
monsieur je fais pas ça mais pourquoi et
à partir de là j'ai effacé en un très
mauvais voyage parce qu'ils visent avant
tout à fait ça après tu es dans ton en
première classe dans ton train avec ton
beau petit costume et chemise sur mesure
qu'est-ce que j'ai pourquoi j'ai fait ça
voilà alors c'est un livre très marrant
parce qu'en général vous parlez avec des
filles qui vous venez de faire l'amour
mais révolution jalonnée de femmes ouais
il y en a un qui est marrant c'est un
mec qui est content de laisser ce que
c'est qu'être condos liste le roi quand
dole dans la grèce antique offrait son
épouse à des soldats c'est quelqu'un qui
ne sait pas expliquer pourquoi il aime
sa femme et pourquoi elle est
exceptionnelle dont il dit et c'est là
non et si si est ce que vous préférez le
camp de l'isthme socialisme largement
on veut faire une spéciale candau lynch
et où les crises alors bruno
sérieusement à arrêter de regarder
combien le trajet toi qui l'avais non
non mais toi tu me regardes mois achetés
dans les yeux alors bruno juin pour vous
le dialogue social est un leurre la
seule solution c'est la révolution
violente et radicale
c'est pas une solution c'est le
questionnement c'est pourquoi elle
n'arrive pas en fait tout est organisé
mais c'est pas des hommes en noir qui
organise ces que la vie va comme ça on
crée des bulles de bonheur aux gens
aient la vie va comme ça mais il ya huit
millions de mecs qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté si on monte légèrement
au dessus on va vite à 15 millions il ya
de l'autre côté des gens qui gagnent
énormément d'argent il n'y a jamais eu
autant de bénéfices remonter à des
actionnaires et pourtant on dit dans les
salaires on n'y touche pas on est dans
une crise monumentale et on s'arrange
quand même mais avec nous jean loup
télévision mais on fait ça toute la
journée on endort au fait en sorte que
la pilule soit tranquille à avaler par
exemple vous vous signalez serré on dit
plus demain il ya grève on dit demain
c'est le bordel ouais mais c'est un
travail de spin doctors des gens qui
sont payés pour ça ils sont dans les
pharmaceutiques ils sont dans
l'agroalimentaire ils sont dans la
télévision évidemment ils sont dans la
politique qui sont partout pour faire en
sorte que une information ne soit pas
interdite mais qu'elles soient minimisés
on peut plus empêcher une info de sortir
c'est très très compliqué par contre en
empêcher la porte est fort et ça c'est
très facile sur les américains appellent
des slows news via que c'est énorme on
va faire en sorte que ce soit ça passe
comme ça tranquillement on a toujours
endormie les gens avant la télé il y
avait les prêtres équidés ans dormait en
leur disant que j'étais très malheureux
ici mais que dans l'au delà ça irait
mieux toujours existé un mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut pas que ça s'arrête
un moment on ne pense pas à ça à faire
ce qu'on fait les tunisiens c'est un
moment dire stop j'y vais tu parles
alors john lennon avait dit la
révolution c'est d'abord dans sa tête
vous dites que la première bastille à
prendre c'est notre propre cerveau tous
les matins voilà et vous êtes assez
conscients de savourer de la solitude du
révolutionnaires de salon au moment de
la confrontation avec le réel oui le
questionnement c'est pourquoi moi qui
vis très bien de cette société je
m'exprime à la télévision je gagne très
bien ma vie ma vie sociale et bien tout
va bien et pourquoi je vis mal ouais
pourquoi j'ai la sensation que ans
vivent bien dans un monde de merde
peut-être que je suis un peu une merde
aussi et je me sens juste un peu pas
bien
j'ai fait que je suis une merde
c'est une règle à ça fait super bien
c'est la prise de conscience qui
s'apprend voilà absolument
arrête toi
c'est une agression douce
way
dont on appelle bruno dans ton appel
pour une société meilleure il ya quelque
chose de patrick sébastien tu le sais
oui tu finiras ta marionnette aux
guignols voudrait faire on s'est quand
même furent tués c'est sûr bien alors on
passe maintenant à ceux qui ont fait
l'actualité de la semaine avec lesdites
ou de blacko et c'est gilles william
goldnadel
président d'avocats sans frontières et
de l'association france-israël que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto
[Musique]
juste après son élection obama s'est
rendu au caire pour s'adresser aux
musulmans du monde entier et leur faire
l'éloge de la démocratie
[Musique]
il faut un gouvernement par le peuple et
pour le peuple
faro ça tombe bien voilà deux ans plus
tard le peuple égyptien réclame
justement le pouvoir mais au lieu de se
réjouir curieusement les américains
s'inquiètent faut dire que ça leur
rappelle un peu ce qui leur est arrivé
en iran en 79 le chah d'iran et est
comme moubarak est un dictateur
pro-américain pouvoir depuis trente ans
comme en egypte il ya eu des manifs et
des morts alors pour sauver la situation
le chat a nommé un premier ministre de
transition avant de fuir le pays un mois
plus tard les islamistes étaient au
pouvoir forcément ce genre de scénario
ça fout la trouille à pas mal de monde
aux américains qui verse plus d'un
milliard de dollars chaque année à
l'armée égyptienne pour stabiliser le
pays et la région aux israéliens
évidemment qui ont signé la paix avec
l'egypte ce chercheur
notre vraie crainte concerne ce qui peut
se passer dans cette situation de chaos
et où un mouvement islamiste organisé
peut prendre le contrôle de l'état mais
ça inquiète aussi des régimes arabes
autoritaires comme la jordanie et
l'arabie saoudite qui craignent le
fameux effet domino cela dit si les
frères musulmans s'installe au pouvoir
en egypte quelles conséquences pour la
tunisie l'algérie le maroc et pendant ce
temps là en iran un moyen-orient
islamique est en train de se construire
et de se dessiner autour de la kz2 la
religion en fait n'a tellement peur
l'islamiste qu'on va finir par être
d'accord avec michèle alliot marie est
ce qu'on ne devrait pas leur proposer
notre savoir-faire dans le maintien de
l'ordre au bout du compte on finit
toujours par se poser publiquement la
même question est ce que le monde arabe
est vraiment prêt pour la démocratie
bayon reproché au pape égyptien son
manque de maturité démocratique
après avoir soutenu pendant des années
la dictature de moubarak ça vous met un
peu mal à l'aise
voilà c'était les vitraux de blacko mise
en image que julien grave gilles william
goldnadel bonsoir vous êtes co fondateur
président d'avocats sans frontières
quasi non l'association france-israël et
vous avez publié le 20 janvier
réflexions sur la question blanche du
racisme blanc au racisme anti blanc chez
jean claude gawsewitch bienvenue parmi
nous merci alors voilà donc les sirènes
du port d'alexandrie ne chante plus la
même mélodie
alors sérieusement ce qui est certain
avec cette crise égyptienne
c'est que plus rien ne sera comme avant
pour israël oui non seulement pour
israël mais pour le monde entier tous
les gens qui sont contre le fascisme
moderne ils ont eu droit également de se
faire du mouron donc celle affaire de
tous la question c'est parce qu'on a
peur de la démocratie c est ce qu on a
peur d'un changement en pire et il ya
pire que moubarak ouais mais ça peut
être les islamistes et ça peut être
aussi l'armée en 59 farouk s'est fait
virer il ya eu l'armée l'armée c'est une
grande chose en egypte et puis la
deuxième réflexion que je vous propose
j'ai l'impression que en france on
préfère être sévère envers les régimes
autoritaires et corrompus
pro-occidentaux converse les régimes
despotiques anti occidentaux on parle
beaucoup de la tunisie et de l'egypte
j'entends moins parler de la libye et de
la syrie enfin israël reste dans la
région la seule puissance atomique oui
non seulement ça mais enfin
israël a besoin d'une égypte pacifique
mais l'egypte quoi qu'il arrive aura
besoin aussi du d'un israël pacifique
dont el sadate quand il a fait la paix
avec israël s'était pas pour les beaux
yeux de béguines déjà du commerce entre
israël et l'egypte francs quand on sent
du gaz
vient d'egypte c'est assez unilatéral
c'est une sphère froide mais c'est la
paix parce qu'il faut dire aussi faut
pas non plus tresser des lauriers à
moubarak mais c'est souvent comme ça
la presse du caire est violemment
antisémite parce que justement il faut
donner des gages aux islamistes
les enfants d'égypte ont été élevés non
seulement au lait anti sioniste mais où
les antisémites ce qui se passe en
égypte ça nous interroge sur notre
propre vision de la démocratie
nous notre démocratie en fait c'est de
choisir entre deux personnes
respectables on a notre vision de la
respectabilité
si on installe ou si on laisse installer
une démocratie en égypte ça veut dire
que les frères musulmans ont le droit de
prêt de se présenter démocratiquement
s'il se présente il ya une chance qu'il
soit majoritaire c'est la démocratie qui
comme le fils en algérie voilà les
frères musulmans qui ne sont absolument
pas sympathique du tout pour l'instant
sur les estimations et représente 40 %
ça n'est quand même pas même si c'est
énorme ce n'est pas la majorité ils ont
déclaré avoir après ce que ça donnera
qu'ils ne seront pas candidats aux
présidentielles
mais il est incontestable qu'ils ont une
influence donc il s'agit de quoi on va
pas continuer à regarder le monde de
façon binaire à croire qu'il ya un bon
on peut choisir et un méchant qu'on peut
exclure donc voila moi je crois que les
universitaires ici en france les
journalistes les militants associatifs
de toutes sortes ont les contributions
apportées en faisant en sorte que la
presse puisse de plus en plus se dégager
du carcan que la parole sera de plus en
plus libre que les ambassades de pays
libre de vraies démocraties
participe à les lui à l'ébullition
culturelle face au centre la démocratie
vive et qu'elle perdure je tempérait un
peu votre romantisme l'islamisme en
egypte c'est une grande chose et ça n'a
rien à voir avec la démocratie donc
quand vous appelez de vos voeux l'action
des universitaires et des intellectuels
si ça se trouve demain ce seront les
premières victimes du prochain régime il
faut arrêter d'imaginer qu'on va trouver
les personnalités qui nous conviennent
dans le moindre détail et il faudra
simplement accompagner tant que nous
pourrons cette marche que l'est le
peuple égyptien lui-même choisi pour la
démocratie et puis après on peut juger
comme on veut chose installé dans notre
confort juger les oeufs et les envies
votre regard intimiste sur les frères
musulmans j'ai le droit de ne pas envier
votre attentisme et bien d'autres si
nancray de vous faire un scénario
catastrophe je vous laisse votre
tendresse pour les frères musulmans
voilà je ne pense pas moins que
l'installation sous jouarre du principal
opposant mohamed el baradaï serait une
bonne nouvelle pour l'occident c'est
quand même lorsqu'il était chargé de
diriger la lagence de contrôle atomique
celui qui est allé regarder de très près
paraît-il les installations iraniennes
et qui a déduit que ne présentait aucun
danger moyennant quoi parce que il avait
évité provisoirement la guerre on lui
attribue le nobel de la paix c'est
munich et baradat si chapour bakhtiar
c'est un match évident il restera trois
jours il ya un truc qui m'a beaucoup
surpris en fait finalement c'est qu'on
dit toujours que la france ait rien vu
venir en tunisie rien d'unir en egypte
mais netanyahu il a l'air aussi largué
que les autres hommage au rock c'est un
échec total de l'ensemble des services
de renseignement ouais parce que les
services de renseignement dans une
conception peut être un petit peu
archaïque des choses aujourd'hui la
révolution elle peut se faire aussi
grâce justement à internet mais ça va
très vite il ya un truc quand même c'est
la position d'obama parce que d'un seul
coup on ne sent pas les américains très
fort sur cette affaire et lire la presse
israélienne a dit l'homme assis à la
maison blanche est capable de nous
vendre en une nuit est-ce que vous
pensez que si bush était resté aux
affaires je vous à se passerait
différemment ou en bouche bouche aussi à
une conception très souvent idéaliste
des choses ils voulaient détruire aussi
le les dictatures en une seconde donc
obama de ce point de vue là a même si
c'est un look anticolonialiste si j'ose
dire à peu près le même défaut dans la
naïveté je considère que la proche de
sarkozy aujourd'hui plus prudente et
plus peuple me paraît plus sage de celle
d'un obama qui accompagne le mouvement
sans trop le comprendre je me permets de
rappeler qu' il ya quelques temps il
avait fait un discours extraordinaire au
caire dans la capitale même de l'homme
qu'il veut défaire en un seul instant et
il ya quelques semaines il faisait la
cour aux dictateurs beaucoup plus
épouvantable de damas avec lequel il
fait des risettes j'ai un peu de mal à
suivre obama en politique étrangère
quand on regarde la carte qui est passé
sur fox news voila voila ou fox news
situe l'egypte donc ça en dit long quand
même sur la nation américaine
aujourd'hui bien marré y voilà est ce
qu'on peut imaginer qu israël
s'accommode à ses frontières d'un état
dans lequel 40 ou 50% de religieux
musulmans dirigerait je parle pas
d'islamisme non non il ya 700 millions
de musulmans autour ils sont 6 millions
vrai il va bien falloir qu'il s'en
accommode un mot mais je je vous réponds
est ce que c'est possible de vivre en
paix comme ça où on va m je vais
maintenant gérer un exemple personnel
c'est boutros boutros ghali qui m'a dit
dans une interview israël sera dense
intense que les royaumes francs et
croisées ont été moins sûr qu'israël
n'existera plus ce sera comme l'algérie
pour vous et le mec était patron de
l'onu oui ils écopent raison pourquoi
les israéliens n'ont pas tort de mon
point de vue lorsque dans le cadre de la
négociation
ils demandent à leurs interlocuteurs
palestiniens ou autres de reconnaître
israël en tant qu'etat du peuple juif ne
reconnaître israël comme israël c'est
d'un intérêt limité dès l'instant où on
reconnaît l'autre dans son identité même
si elle vous plaît pas forcément je
crois qu'on avance en ce moment
vous avez raison au maghreb et au
machrek on n'en est pas là du tout
philippe hamon on voit ce qu'on crée les
différents traités depuis près de 75 ans
d état artificiel et dont les frontières
non non non pas tenu longtemps et puis
je ne suis pas persuadé que les français
soient sensibilisés suffisamment à tout
ça il y en a beaucoup qui quand on leur
part de la bande de gaza crois que c'est
une association de malfaiteurs ce sera
le mot de la fin
voilà j williams merci d'avoir été avec
no mercy donc nous on se retrouve après
la planète 2 à 10 ans
notre amitié du samedi 20 heures ce soir
lorenzo magazine
il a tué
[Musique]
bonsoir de galère nous sommes toujours
en compagnie de philippe bouvard
christiane taubira
gaccio
et vous accueillir leurs invités du
samedi 20 heures ce soir lorenzo selon
magali bonsoir
alors lorenzo
votre témoignage met en lumière l'un des
derniers grands tabous de notre société
la sexualité des handicapés est question
corollaire faut-il créer en france un
statut d'assistant sexuel pour les
handicapés comme c'est le cas en
allemagne aux pays bas au danemark en
suisse vous êtes suisse vous vivez à
zurich vous êtes donc ostéopathe est
également assistant sexuel sas madame
bachelot s'oppose à ce que ça soit créée
en france vous nous raconter votre
histoire à 20 heures en attendant
j'accueille stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mais d'abord le zapping
c'était le zapping avoue stéphane pour
la semaine brion
après fram voyages ouverture d'une
nouvelle agence mam voyage
même voyage je vous propose de survoler
en jet privé des pays à feu et à sang en
compagnie d'un dictateur ou d'un membre
de sa famille offrez-vous une vue du
ciel sur les plus belles et me du
maghreb gazage matraquage soyez le
témoin privilégié d'un instant
historique tout en bénéficiant du
confort d'un jet privé mam voyage le
plus beau point de vue du monde sur la
souffrance humaine
mam
sophie favier renonce est candidate aux
élections cantonales de neuilly sur
seine c'est con
jean sarkozy aurait pu la battre
intellectuellement il avait enfin
quelqu'un à sa mesure
brice hortefeux va faire suivre les
délinquants sexuels
en revanche les délinquants condamné
pour injures racistes ne seront pas
suivis brice hortefeux peut donc
continuer à se balader tranquille
sarkozy annonce le recours à des jurés
populaires en correctionnelle
avant la fin de l'année ce qui serait
bien c'est que ce soit retransmis sur
tf1 animée par eric zemmour et qu'on
puisse voter 20 ans ferme pour mohamed
tapez 1 là ça serait génial
jacques chirac at-il la maladie
d'alzheimer une photo en particulier
inquiète regardez sur ce cliché l'ancien
président s'interroge pourquoi lui at on
a tâché un morceau de tissu du coup
c'est une cravate monsieur chirac c'est
décoratif tous les matins bernadette
vous en avez une bon rétablissement
deux autres clichés inquiète sur cette
photo jacques chirac arrive dans une
réunion avec bernadette et une heure
plus tard il repart avec michèle
alliot-marie
terrible maladie bernadette est quand
même beaucoup plus sexy et rigolote
kallio marche
au maire de saint-amand qui déploraient
le manque de moyens pour sa commune
nicolas sarkozy a répondu on ne peut pas
dépenser plus je n'accepterai pas que la
france fasse la manche oui ça suffit
maintenant les frais on a dépensé 178
millions d'euros pour l'avion
présidentiel
donc si la crèche tombe en ruine si la
maison de retraite s'écroule vous vous
démerdez la mairie on se serre la
ceinture ça suffit la gabegie
[Applaudissements]
en sortant du bureau de dsk au fmi
christine boutin a déclaré être persuadé
qu'il ne serait pas candidat à la
présidentielle
les vexer boutin a les vexer en entrant
dans le bureau de dsk elle était sûre
qui lui arriverait quelque chose tout y
passe les vieilles et negro ce les
moches hélas rien l'a très mal pris du
coup elle est sortie elle a raconté
n'importe quoi
la production de cocaïne grignote la
forêt colombienne est ce qu'on peut voir
une photo de la forêt avant que jean luc
delarue deux faces de la télé
magnifique et après oh [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
on enchaîne on enchaîne avec une
nouvelle très triste on l'a appris cette
semaine carla bruni ne se sent plus de
gauche eh bien nous allons revoir des
images de carla quand elle était de
gauche
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci la fédé à merci merci une page se
tourne
[Applaudissements]
c'est officiel le film de woody allen
midnight in paris avec carla bruni
ouvrira le prochain festival de cannes
nicolas sarkozy s'est réjoui de cette
décision
mais coûter cher
je suis très heureux
c'est un film formidable
woody allen a eu le génie de montées les
unes à la suite des autres les 35
risques ont été nécessaires à carlita
pour acheter une baguette dans une
boulangerie
et je peux vous dire thierry ardisson
que dès la troisième prise tout le
public mort de rire
ses plus grands films comiques de woody
allen avec paris lyndon orange mécanique
excusez moi je me trompe de fiches
c'est plus grands films de woody allen
avec manhattan what's new pussycat prend
l'oseille et tire toi prends l'oseille
et tire-toi trier qui résume
parfaitement la gestion de mon
quinquennat
aller à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup merci
en face maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20
[Musique]
lorenzo re bonsoir vous avez 49 ans vous
êtes marié père de deux garçons de 20 et
22 ans vous êtes ostéopathe dans la
banlieue de zurich
et depuis quelques années vous êtes
également assistant sexuel
comment et pourquoi
un père de famille passionnée de jazz a
décidé de devenir un jour assistants
sexuels quel impact cette activité a eu
sur vos proches et surtout en quoi
consiste l'assistance sexuelle nous
allons tenter de répondre à ces
questions vous êtes né le 20 mai 1961
dans le sud de la suisse première année
à milan ça se voit de père travaille
pour la swissair
ensuite il est muté à bangkok quand vous
avez deux ans vous y est resté six ans
et donc des huit ans quand vous revenez
en suisse à lugano
l'école ne vous passionne pas seule la
musique vous intéresse et malgré la
pression de vos parents vous entré à
vingt ans au conservatoire de jazz de
berne alors en 1981 vous rencontrer
carine que vous épouserais et qui
deviendra la mère de vos deux enfants là
vous faites un petit boulot à l'aéroport
de zurich vous vous cherchez à cette
époque là et un jour vous listez vos
ambitions sur une feuille de papier vous
mettez un ébéniste deux pilotes de ligne
3 ostéopathe et vous serez bénisse
pendant 16 ans oui un grand bonheur j'ai
pu à travailler
dans une ferme quand acheter et le grand
bonheur c'était celui de pouvoir
combiner le travail avec l'éducation des
enfants jusqu'au jour où vos enfants ont
rendez vous avec une conseillère
d'orientation et là votre femme karine
et vous en profiter pour faire une sorte
de bilan de compétences vous posez la
question de votre devenir on vous dit
vous manquez de contact humain il me dit
ben entre entre les choses que je
pourrais faire ça ce serait une activité
comme ma soeur ostéopathe c'est
incroyable c'est un problème parce que
là je me suis dit pas jamais une fois
déjà une c'était le troisième à
troisième ligne azad de votre papier là
vous allez prendre quatre ans de cours
et ouvrir un cabinet d'ostéopathie voilà
et un jour en lisant le journal vous
tombez sur un article où il est question
de la sexualité des handicapés
une association qui s'appelle pro
infirmis qui est spécialisé là dedans et
qui lance un programme de formation
d'assistant sexuel et là vous vous
rendez compte que vous avez un ami
handicapé qui s'appelle hans un ébéniste
et vous n'avez jamais pensé à sa
sexualité jusqu'à ce jour là finalement
renoncé
je peux peut-être même gêné de ça mais
c'est la réalité alors le soir votre
femme vous tend un article et elle vous
dit tiens lis ça ça serait bien pour toi
et c'est le même article oui ça c'est
dit emotionnellement c'était très fort
parce que je me suis rendu compte de la
valeur de
de carrick et qui m'a donné la
possibilité de faire quelque chose dont
je me sentais
très très
capable enfin alors karine le soutien
vos enfants n'accepteront assez
facilement même si pour le plus petit
c'est un peu plus compliqué c'est ça oui
il faut qu'un jour il quelqu'un qui
liste que fait-on père c'est formidable
pour qu'ils acceptent réellement en fait
c'est ça il avait un peu honte quoi oui
oui oui bien sûr mais maintenant on en
parle très ouvertement et ouais c'est
pas de problème alors ce programme il ya
300 candidats
il y en a dix qui sont retenus dont vous
voilà
et alors là commence la formation c'est
à dire que d'abord il faut faire le
point sur votre propre sexualité c'est
pas pensable de de pouvoir faire de
l'assistance de d'aider quelqu'un dans
sa sexualité si on n'a pas réfléchi sur
la propre vie sexuelle c'est vraiment
une biographie sexuel qu'on a qu'on a
fait ensuite il ya les études des
différents types de handicap
oui il y en a beaucoup c'est ça c'est
impossible de tout les étudier ces mêmes
pas afin important de connaître tous les
mécaniques des handicaps c'est
finalement en 2004 que vous obtenez
votre diplôme d'assistant sexuel voilà
la première assistance que vous faites
c'est avec une italienne atteinte
d'amyotrophie
vous avez rendez vous avec elle dans un
hôtel c'est ça oui vous aviez le trac en
y allant ben oui bien sûr quand même la
première fois pour moi une expérience
en fait même gigantesque c'est vraiment
le moment pratique alors vous lui faites
quoi vous lui fait des caresses érotique
quoi c'est ça oui bon moi je fais ce que
le client là client désire ça c'est très
important je fais je fais pas plus et si
j'ai si j'arrive à
à gérer les voeux des clients alors
c'est sympa oui oui ça s'est bien passé
donc à rester aux tic sur le dos les
saints l'entrejambes a été contente oui
absolument oui prix 150 euros j'ai aussi
un tarif social si à noël des personnes
qui qui qui n'ont pas des moyens c
dans le monde des handicapés il ya des
riches et des moins riches comme partie
nation alors c'est un art très spéciale
parce que vous dites parfois il faut un
quart d'heure pour enlever un pantalon
ou quoi c'est des gens qui sont
handicapés mais il n'y a aucune
aucune gêne 6 il faut du temps pouvant
ne serait ce que pour ceux des alliés
lorsque vous faites c'est des caresses
superficiel il n'y a pas de pénétration
n'y a pas de sexe oral c'est ça les
limites que vous avez de 10 et c'est ce
que moi j'ai posé ouais mais chacun fait
comme il veut c'est d'accord alors le
plus important évidemment cc
l'inventivité et l'empathie et le coeur
qu'on y met finalement oui une chose
quand et qu'il faut pas oublier c'est la
capacité de découpe
même si quelqu'un ne peut pas parler est
une chose très importante c'est de avant
tout assistants sexuels
en mai en clair le fait de dire non
alors il ya aussi une dimension
humoristique vous dites parfois on se
retrouve dans des positions absurde et
on éclate de rire voilà c'est ça que
j'aime parce que en fait la sexualité
c'est la vie c'est le bien-être c'est le
soulagement donc il ya vraiment parfois
des situations très drôle aussi
et j'ai noté que les les personnes
handicapées aime aussi rire de leurs
propres dits cap alors au fil des
expériences vous découvrez différents
types de personnes assistées il ya un
homme avec qui vous êtes obligé dans le
vente et un alphabet pour pour
communiquer il est mentalement à
très handicapée quoi même on a on a pu
ajouter qu est-ce que les valets un
alphabet personnel entre entre nous deux
donc c'est ça qui qui qui fait de
l'assistance sexuelle une activité
très complexe alors idées d'histoires
très émouvante évidemment vous raconter
l'histoire d'une dame qui peut et 20 kg
20 minutes pour la placer sur le lit
sans lui faire mal sont là évidemment
parce que très fragile ensuite elle vous
demande d'aider karev c est la sortie
elle se met à pleurer elle vous dit j'ai
dû attendre quarante ans pour pouvoir
goûter à ça c'est extraordinaire un des
moments les plus émouvants que j'ai fait
pour moi c'était vraiment dur après de
reprendre la compense ainsi extrêmement
répétant sans alors vous vous occupez
surtout des femmes si vous êtes et
théorie sexuelle donc c'est oui j'ai
parlé avant de dung quât masculin c'est
le cas où il
il avait des problèmes avec sa sexualité
que j'ai pu l'aider qui ne se masturbe
soi-même et
c'était une apothéloz la première fois
qu'il a pu faire ça c'est vraiment
comme s'il l'avait découvert sa
masculinité les résultats sont probants
sont positifs vous apprenez aux
handicapés à aimer leur corps et surtout
ça supprime souvent l'agressivité oui on
ne peut pas vivre notre sexualité en
devient frustré on devient
rigide et c'est là qu'il ya des
violences extrêmes qui peuvent surgir et
assistants sexuels peuvent vraiment à
donner des soulagements alors il ya
aussi un grand avantage c'est que ça
supprime l'inceste parce que souvent les
mamans soit le masturbe leurs enfants
handicapés soient elles le font pas ce
qui est terrible pour l'enfant on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de parents surtout les
mamans
qui aident dans la sexualité de leurs
enfants et des adultes bien sûr ce qui
ce qui a
eu lieu de résoudre un problème on pose
un autre alors voilà aujourd'hui vous
faites ça 30 à 40 fois par an un oui à
peu près en dehors de votre boulot dodo
jeté aux pattes alors en france dans
cruising bachelot et est opposé à ça on
va l'écouter derrière j'entends la
misère de certaines personnes vous avez
peut-être un fils ou une fille à petit
fils une petite fille est ce que voulait
conseilleriez ce métier d'assistant
sexuel donc enfin je sais pas demandez
aux auditeurs d'europe 1 s'il
conseillerait cela leur fils ou leur
fille ce à quoi vous répondez
si le fils ou la fille de madame
bachelot était handicapée elle aurait
sans doute une ou deux positions il faut
qu'on se rend compte il faut il faut
rien pour que nous on est dans cette
situation donc après c'est à nous deux
voir qu'est ce qu'on fait avec notre
sexualité que tout à coup et est tombé
en panne mais en panne gigantesque au
madame bachelot c'est pas le sujet on ne
compte pas lorsqu'on a des
responsabilités politiques on ne prend
pas des décisions par rapport à son fils
ou sa fille qui seraient dans cette
situation là assez absolument
désespérant d'entendre des responsables
de politiques raisonner comme ça est-ce
que c'est toujours les mêmes clients la
plupart des fans oui oui parce qu'étant
donné que moi je jeu à 6 des femmes
les femmes aiment bien qu' il y ait une
continuité et ça crée un lien
ça peut créer un lien c'est clair c'est
un
discours très très important a peut être
un lien amoureux
qui peut être amoureux est unilatéral
c'est ça c'est en aidant j'ai jeu c'est
un danger c'est un discours à apprendre
sur sérieux il faut en parler moi je
suis
une aide sexuelle je devrais peut-être
même à 1
boncompain mais je suis pas le
partenaire je sais bien sûr quelque
chose qui me gène seulement monsieur a
donc il l'a dit tout à l'heure un
cabinet d'ostéopathe puissiez sûrement
prospère est-ce que sa démarche ne
pourrait pas être plus humanitaire
est ce que cette vocation ne serait pas
plus admirable si elles s'exerçaient
sans argent c'est dangereux donc dans
l'autre sens parce que le
danger
qu'après s'il n'y avait pas l'argent ça
veut dire
oui c'est à dire que c'est l'argent qui
est une barrière contre la perversité
non pas contre la partie texte contre
l'amour oui comme la psychanalyse oui
oui c'est exactement pour ce à dire que
vous appelez vos vos patiente des
clients dit justement parce qu'il ya de
l'argent en transit nécessaire et
comment ça se passe avec karine s'est
absolument pas là l'activité de
l'assistance sexuelle qui est reposante
repose dans notre vie sexuelle il prend
quelqu'un pour ça
merci à tous
c'était salut les terriens avec philippe
genre
y avait chez flammarion et les grosses
têtes tous les jours sur l'ancien fils
yann taubira merci d'avoir été un des
pions députée de guyane bruno gaccio
pour la révolution on se rappelle
j'étais quartier compagnie gilles
william goldnadel président d'avocats
sans frontières et de l'association
france-israël
lorenzo fut madame merci
je vous rappelle que l'on bâtit jeu sera
au casino de paris le 14 février avec
son spectacle laurent baffie est un sale
gosse allez-y c'est pas de la merde
enfin je vous signale de la fédération
des aveugles de france a édité un
calendrier
réunissant de nombreuses personnalités
afin de sensibiliser et l'opinion à
propos de la malvoyance qui touche un
million et demi de gens en france merci
à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire cette
émission je voulais c'est réglé savez
des émissions et devant le point de
conte pour les abonnés à 20h50 conflit
avec emmanuelle devos et gilbert melki
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine et
d'ici là salutaire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu